いやー
ついにこの日が来てしまったかあのまあ長男の日かといいますと
第一君という今外れシャツの歯だけのメンバーなんですけども
大地くんというですね結構前から始め社長のチャンネルの裏方
ずっと顔出さずに裏方で活動を仕事してもらってたんですけども
その彼が辞めるということで最後の強化ネット取る最後の
動画になると思います
まぁちょっとん
長いですねースキーが長いし皆さん的にはその肇社長の
ずっと側近でいている麻布でお仕事してみてどうだったとか
まぁちょっと肇社長の畑という単独やってみてどうだったかなとか俺と言う音が一緒に
てどうだったのかとかいろいろ聞いてみたいと思います開きましたね
って言っ
ua 日クソのこそもう歳頃
最後進まず最後に俺やーだけだしたはい
まあとりあえず
肇社長の
[音楽]
まあ側近って言い方も馬場かんなですけども的調べたらね2016年の10月から
ん
働いてもらって豊富4年間です
長い間本当にありがとうございますありがとうございます卒業式っぽいのはの畑で出
てる
力ちょっと泣いちゃったんでもないことはないとねまあいろいろねその髪に一つの裏方
の人間が4年間どう思ってたとかちょっと聞いてみたいなと
なーんとにロソ here いつかもっともっとはじめちゃんのチャンネルの
なかった編集と作ってて書いてよねそこから2年前に畑を作るってことでかわして
動画作ってもらったんですけど4年からどうでした
いやーそうですね
いやでも本当にます楽しかったですっ
ちゃったん全部をまとめる楽しかったほんとポンッと
会でも弾くはねやっぱもう4年前から変わらない
もずーっとまあ
良くも悪くもねー良くも悪くもってがまあまあ我が道をずっと言ってるんで
なんかそれについていくのがすごく楽しくて
何だろうやっぱ普通に生活してただけじゃこう体験できないことも体験できる1弾と
なっていうのがあって
なんだもうすごい
うーん楽しかったし
何度も人に自慢できるような感じでこういう2できないことできるぞっていう
のもあって
すごいなんか勉強になった4年間だよねあるしいろんな音後輩とか
畑のみんなとかすごいねたくさんの中仲間
っとやってこれって凄い良かったのって
出会い方がすごく素敵なんです第一気になるぞえってで行ったかっていうとまずいう行
カードなんですけどそう
たまたまカードショップで
だだ5くれさあ俺がと知り合う前のモールの友達知らんしょ
白スランそしら混ぜ友田つっていないスマ事項力がないからほんと様悠様カードという
趣味が始めたきっかけで知られた友達ってのが大地くんで有用かどうやっていくうちに
ね
そんな中でなかった気がすんだよなぜなんてまずそもそも初めて見た時に俺の友達通せ
ないなぁそうだったね
うーんなるんですけどおれしらんから飼っだれっ
1社のあたのはいう気はする中にはいたけど大好きヴォルさん
話すほどねちょっとひとつどうぞ何度高
消せる何とも云え関係だった曲あるの
そうだねうんそっから
なねー今ない
なったものなんでだろう俺逆に多分でその
興味ない感じが心地よかったのかなぁなるほどねか喋っ
ミランダカーんじゃなくてん
くれ
総嗣 youtube 自体まったく興味がないと言ったら知ってるかもしれないけど
全く知らないし有名だよとれても
ぐらいやったね俺そういう
第5区のところがきっかけというかでかい
何か立った気がするれますあっという間
こんなラーメンなという意味だったり作ってあったとき4年前でしょ
22さんとかよカーボ207よヤバイよもう
なっちゃう
だいずくんがこの仕事を
やめるというか回目のたぶんいろんな理由があると思うけど
どんなんですかいろんな音が擦ってるんだけどでもやっぱり何だろう
コート紙になったからこそ
何だろうこう自分でできることって少なくなってくるじゃんだんだん年取ってくると
本当にそれ放送
この中でんなんか
ちょうどねこの前に17歳になったときに何かやりたいことを
他になんかあるのかなみたいな感じで色々探しててそしたら今ので新しい
働く場所っていうのを見つけ見つかってそうだねもう
挑戦してみたいって何で夏どうでしたいやいやもう5人的にねやっぱりそうなんだよね
なんかねやっぱねを回り
親とか言われるのはまあやりたいことができた
のいいけどこのご時世大丈夫本当にやだなんかやめたいっていうかその予算者の聞いて
ちょっとしてからこういうことになったからまあそうだね i-miev やべえと
そういうホットシューカツも上手くいくのか心配だった
その時中もあやべえとなったんだけどでもやっぱりこうね探してみるという音結婚
なくはないことだからあとは自分の頑張り次第なと思ってまあ正直8大学の英学卒業し
て就職したじゃん自分その時より就活
た豊後梅がまったと思うマジそうだね本音を言うとこうやっぱ youtube って
他の小企業ところするとなんか+でミラー見られるぶー
とマイナスで見られるんだけどがあるぞそりゃね目想像だがない鹿も顔でてるかさは
就活の時がそれがプラスに働くのか
そうそうマイナスに働くのかって言う
まぁねぇ結論からいうとどっちもだよねやっぱりちょっと校
[音楽]
here tube here なかった部はけど逆
にそれこそ次の自分が働く場所がすごい youtube ベルかおお
そんな逆にそんな体型してる人なんて滅多にないから
私なんです
ぜひそういうを生かしてほしいすごいいいところに巡り会えたなってるな
良くも悪くも
ですよ準2番の皆さんそうですよ本当に大変ですよ
いやー
感じですねニャー話す影響もそんなこと言ってられないからなんても悲しい
なんかさんもう就職しちゃって次の場所でも全然
遊びこれないとかそういうのだったらすごいこれをもっといけるけど
だから現状はね全然普通に遊べ休みの日とかも遊びこれるし
今まで通りね丸鶏
はいかないけどそれなりには結構会う機会もあるのかなと言う
のがあるから
大食い時米入っもしくは何かあれ
飯によるすごいライン際くれたりするから遊びせ本当にまた新しく
一からスタートするんで
何だろう youtube でできなかったことができなかったことになる事務局
youtube やってるだけじゃやっぱね本当にねこれまで3重なになってそれが
たまに脳裏をよぎるんすよそうだかそういうことも結構いろいろ挑戦していきたいな
みたいな
いや俺今の仕事めちゃくちゃ好き分
小やりたいと思うけども
[音楽]
今できなかったってのはマジで本絶対に言うじゃんメッツはめっちゃいうで
いやほんと様自粛で家にずっと入ったらぐらいも何もないからだしてね割とガチで
ヤバイんじゃないか死刑っていう気はしてます
まあそれもね自分中之坊 a
うにゃんニーズなダサいわねぇ
大付も活動けどねかー
天気の瞬間だとそう27歳もなんでもないやんだけどなんかちょっといろいろ焦る時期
出番ですよね
若いけど若くなり創造そうそう席一般化したばかりかもしれないけどやっぱ周りが交差
いろんな結婚とか子供とか本当にと思いますねそこでちょっと
ああっとなるんだよありがヤバイ周りが尿創造
何かあれば
楽しんでくれて7が良かったわよねんがぁもすっごい灯子ってよ
を添えてくれたら9
選んだけどねぇ
ずっともたいと言ってくれたとユーロあったよねぇ
いやーすごいそれから本当に私は大臣とした時にずっといてくれた人間で俺が多分様
やりたいことを
しかやらない人間だからサポートしてくれる
裏方で頑張ってくれたら大地くんがねすごい柔らかいにいけて良かったね
やらへんというかそのずうなぁ性があるというかこっちに対応して動いてくれてるから
ものやめちゃくちゃやりやすかもしれないがぶつかることもまあそれがいいのか悪いの
かわからんけどねまあ確かにね
ぶつかっていいときもあるけれども俺はぶつからずに数
行けてもこう仕事できてるんだなすごいやりやすかったよう
有名ですよねずっとよちょっと緊張する本当に
[音楽]
大変なことはめっちゃ嘘それをそれをねーそう
あー速度ず逆にいいとこばっかりねやっぱりで夢見ちゃう人もいるんですけどたしか
言いますけどねさ現実問題ですね
実はまーうん
割合でいうと楽しいが
ロック大変が4結構いい
完全に想像楽しい部分で言うとやっぱりこうてねみんなで好きな子となるし自分たちが
やりたいことができる
普段出来ない事も体験できることがあるんだけども
うーん何だろう大変な部分で言うとやっぱり今凍ってね
動画見てくださってるけどなんかそれを取るまでの工程ところだし金なんかいうなれば
幸1本の映画とかそういう感じじゃないですか
自分で企画考えて
カメラで撮影して編集して
っていうのがすっごいそれだ楽しい部分であるんだけど
まあ大変とが一番この部分でもあるから
ん
それとかそうだねあとはなんかこう
ちょっと校
みんた文はじめも一番多く体が私はちょっと待ってまずはってなってたんだなって
ん
俺は員がすげーないちゃんとやれないん
レダきたわけないんだけどゆきゃでに俺なんかないからなんかいつ冷徹な波ですね
まあこれがねさようならって起こらないと思うと
[音楽]
よねえ
だしなんか
僕たち見たくねえ
ねぇ
街同士じゃなくてみんなでね朝ごはんー
そうかという中ば土地が違うところもあるからなんかそういったところでねみんな何を
持っていってことか
人間関係で悩むこともあるし
それはね俺も最近年歯だけで思ったんそしたりねってきてあったから
自分の意思で吊らぐっんじゃなくて叩けばとかね
もうにず出るとそういう大変さもちょっと
第二軍リーダーだったからそういう負担もあったのかなって俺はずっと
負担はないけど
やっぱり難しいなと思うことはたくさんあったかな
たぶん初めて一番感じている部分かもしれないけどなんかこう
社会から打つとこう
1個置かれているちょっとなんだろ違う感じで生きてるの見たし金のもあるし
良くも悪くもそういったときにちょっと孤独感じるときもあるし
周りの友達とかといういればさんでで話も
アブあるから合わないところもあるん
達増がに乗って
まあなんか何かそういったか配る人があったら楽しめるかなーっていう自分がやりたい
ことを発信できる
混血がなん
ましてずっと一緒にあたりで大地くんな
動くからさぁ俺もあって言っちゃうわけです年齢が同じって言うのがあると思う
あとそうなぜそれはデカいところ
まさき村もそうだったけどなんかこう親父アンっていうか自分が後抜ける3で申し訳
ないけど
もちろん畑の人もじゃないけどそれ以前のそっちが結構いなくなっちゃうわけ
[音楽]
大丈夫だなーとかっていう風に時もあるけど
いやもう
そうだねうん
安かったけどやばい不安になってきたぞライブ大丈夫ではその座れ
先も大好きなんだけど過去の俺をねたくさん知っている人が
いなくなるので不安なんだなぁ肇社長でドッカーンで上のとこにいるけど俺も全部知っ
てるわけじゃないけどその過程でも大変なこといっぱいしたから競って日本一になる前
からいたものですからそうだねそうなんかねえ
きたくないんですけどねいろんな動画を撮ったからそれを
振り返ると日
[音楽]
玄関よろしくです
大学生している畑が
始まる前を
ねふたりで
[音楽]
嘘だって
保存ばに立ってたねゼンマイとのびのびとうそれならん
それはそこはあるかもねその2人だってたらもう何か
[笑い]
ブーバーみんなそれだとまとまり
ができないからそう
ね人数増えると
大変なこともできることも広がるけどねでもなければ
好きなようにやればいいとべよホント
ちょっといつまで強するか分から去年ぞね
ずた妹がありますからどんどん南下一のこしたことはないです
畑に何か言ってあげなくてちょっと奴らのやりづらいぞ
映ってほしい
なんかねさっきも言ったんだけどなんかこう
みんな結構支え合ってやってるんだけどまだ公演場する部分があると思うがそれね
すごい
本人としたごらんから言うけどねまぁ俺もすねそうな感じだからこう
いけないけど
何だろうなぁもっとこう一つのチームというか
なるためにはもっとこう一人ひとりが自分はもっと出しちゃっていいんじゃないかなっ
ていう
何かもっと何でも俺なしでチめたまになんだろうと思うんですよ
痛いことだったらほとんどん
入ってって欲しいんで本当にあとあれだねもっとこう
はじめとこんな取った部屋はいおれけんかじゃなくて
だからタイトルに坂が歳の嘘は伊藤出し後動画とかでもうなんか行為
直ちに泣けるぞみたいな感じでやって例えば何だこの野郎みたいな
ああいうやりとりが欲しいなん
俺大地くんがで結構みんなはそんな俺目指したねやってやってるんじゃないけど結構
唯一歯向かってくれたけどねぇんあんたら何だよ何だねぇ
えっ
ジムシャツ恐れないでほしいですねそうね切り分け畑のみなさん聞いてます
突然減って申し訳ないけどそういうことでございなんかもうそうなればもうねみんな
一人一人すごいね
なんかすごいも持ってるからそういうのがもう取っ払っちゃいま
なんかすっごい俺の中では一番面白いそうじゃなと思うから頑張って欲しいですね
滅他人事みたいですね俺もガラガラだったというわけでみなさん
年間か
年間はじめした超の
とともに
仕事をしてくださった大一クンでした寂しくなるなぁって叩き鑿のみてたよねー
菅そうなそう
下す子車歴史自分からこう食べた津川だとしてもこれからは
ねえ
なんかもう
二名の社長も畑の埠頭ではなくなっちゃうかもしれないけど
視聴者というかする側として
だけの活躍でああ
かけながら公演できたん
応援してます
頑張るから5弦の分も余って入れました
ありがとうございましたほんとっ
war 戦は誰サークルがバックっ
th
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
ねぇ
[音楽]
ありがとうんとっ
が入ってないんだけどねえ早いか時代じゃないんだけどね見どころに直してんじゃね
は
気軽に何でも言っていっ
[音楽]
なんで力ととかっ
ブーブー会員ヌー
[音楽]